- Beyonce came, which
- Oh my God!
- Was like, I mean
- [Kelly] Texas Queen!
- [Ben] What do you do
at that point? Oh no!
- Look at her, just in her average day
still looking hotter than the rest of us.
- Just me slowly passing away,
(chuckles uncomfortably)
Just completely,
- Is she like, your like,
(sings harmoniously)
- Yeah. I mean it was like
an alien descended
- She's a lot of people, yeah
- She is, and I like saw her,
that's another example
where I really wanted
to know if she was
there 'cause I'm looking
in the audience and you
see just like the shape
of her weave
- Yeah
- You're just like, if I had
- spotted that, I think I would have
just passed out, so I was happy
to know exactly where she
was gonna be and that she was coming.
- On my gosh, we're so different,
I would never wanna know. Um,(chuckles)
Have you ever freaked
out on anyone, Tyler?
Like meeting them?
- Well, well
Well now that we're mentioning Beyonce,
she was at my party
recently, she and Jay-Z.
- [Tyler] Yeah she was
at my party recently
(Tyler chuckles)
- He's got all the cool stuff!
- Now, one person, just one person,
and that was Nelson Mandella.
- Oh wow!
- Freaked out, yeah. I got a chance
to sit down and talk to him, so,
not to up yours, but I just
- What did you say?
- I (mumbles), that's
all I could say, so yeah
Oprah made that happen, yeah
I got a chance to sit down
- That's incredible
And talk to him, so yeah
- It's so nice when Oprah does stuff
for you, right?
- And I'm still name dropping!
- Totally
- This is so bad! Sorry!
- I was on the phone with O the other day
too Tyler, and, no I wasn't
- It's bad though when I'm talking
to friends and I start hearing myself
say things and they're looking at me like
- But it's so second nature to you because
it is your life!
And you're not meaning
to be weird about it!
- No, not at all, but it just seems like,
it is, yeah, you know I was talking to
- But just so you know it ain't normal
- Yeah
(Kelly laughs)
- I was talking to Michelle,
The lady that work for the
bank? No, Obama, and it's like,
So those kind of moments, yeah
- And people are like, what?
- I just, I gotta do better
- Your life is awesome,
- I gotta do better
- That's what we've discovered